I'm on Bondi Beach in Sydney Australia
and I want to talk to you about ozone
because there's an interesting paper
that's just been published about ozone
and the effect on the weather in
Australia
let's start with oxygen in the
atmosphere that is oxygen perhaps 30
kilometers above the Earth's surface now
imagine an o2 molecule here this can
absorb ultraviolet light from the Sun
and the energy of the absorb light can
blow the molecule apart so you now have
two oxygen atoms and because the
atmospheric pressure is low
these will fly apart here I've got
another oxygen atom that's been formed
by dissociating o - and if it flies
along and hits another OH - molecule so
we have o plus o - they can react to
form ozone which is oh three and oh
three ozone is another form of oxygen
which is highly colored it's a sort of
dark blue color the molecule and as it
sits in the upper atmosphere it absorbs
the harmful UV light and stops it coming
down to the Earth's surface with very
high intensity and protects us all from
the effects of the sunlight and in fact
the ozone absorbs light itself and falls
apart to form o to an oxygen but this
oxygen atom can recombine to make more
ozone so there's an equilibrium the
ozone is falling apart but it's being
made at the same rate as it falls apart
this is what happened until people
started using aerosols for things like
styling their hair you know and when
they started making these aerosols in
the aerosols they put a molecule rather
like this which has carbon in the middle
three fluorine atoms and a chlorine atom
so this is C F 3 CL I've used another
earth but it's much bigger so this is
chlorine so here we have a molecule
which in itself is completely harmless
with three fluorines and a chlorine
bonded to the carbon but when this when
you spray your hair or you used to with
old-fashioned hair sprays these
molecules went into the atmosphere and
floated around and eventually got up to
30 kilometers high and when they got
there this molecule would absorb UV
light and expel the chlorine atom so now
high up above your surface as well as
the oxygen atoms you have a chlorine
atom and the chlorine atom could can
react with ozone and remove one of the
oxygens so you now have CL o CL o is not
very stable and so it reacts further to
release the chlorine atom so the
chlorine atom will go on and knock out
one ozone molecule after another until
it's probably knocked out perhaps a
thousand ozone molecules the effect is
that these molecules here with fluorine
chlorine and carbon the so called CFCs
can if they get into the atmosphere
start destroying the ozone layer what is
particularly striking is the effect that
you get over the poles the Antarctic and
the Arctic because over the Antarctic
and Arctic you get very small ice
crystals in the air and the chlorine
atoms can be adsorbed onto the surface
of the ice crystals during the polar
night when the Sun is not shining onto
the surface of the of the earth and then
when the Sun comes back up in the spring
like the spring now in the southern
hemisphere then a large amount of
chlorine is released all at once and it
can completely destroy the ozone causing
a so-called ozone hole
where the UV light can get right down to
the Earth's surface
of course there's very little life in
the Antarctic so the UV light going down
does not affect many organisms but what
it does do is that it changes
circulation patterns in the atmosphere
and this recent paper suggests that the
whole ozone hole over the Antarctic is
in fact causing rainfall to shift
southwards from Australia and therefore
might explain the droughts and things
that have been happening recently on
this continent now you might ask why is
the effect worse in the southern
hemisphere than the northern hemisphere
and the answer is really simple because
if you look at the earth let's turn the
chlorine back into the earth and look at
the earth you can see the Antarctic is a
landmass whereas the Arctic on the other
side is sea so the temperatures over the
Antarctic are much lower than those of
the Arctic so you get far more of these
ice crystals in the air
and therefore the effect on the chlorine
and the atmospheric chemistry is much
more pronounced scientists first
discovered the effects of CFCs and
chlorine in the atmosphere in the late
1970s and shortly afterwards the use of
CFCs in aerosols was banned but so many
of them have already been released in
the atmosphere they're still slowly
drifting up to the upper atmosphere from
the near the ground where we first
released them so the effect with the
Arctic and Antarctic ozone holes is
going to persist for many more years but
eventually the CFCs will be washed out
of the atmosphere and all being well
this problem will disappear there's one
extra twist the ozone in the upper
atmosphere is really very beneficial
life on Earth wouldn't really exist
without it
the ozone in the lower atmosphere near
the Earth's surface is not at all good
because ozone is a very reactive
molecule it can lose oxygen in all sorts
of different ways reacting with organic
compounds and can cause serious health
problems to people and over the last
century or so the amount of ozone near
the Earth's surface has increased
because of a number of reactions in the
atmosphere promoted by the Sun usually
involving oxides of nitrogen which can
be produced by emissions from car
exhausts and so on and recently the
Royal Society produced a report on the
effect of ozone near the Earth's surface
so called ground-level ozone their real
worries that ozone at ground level is a
serious health problem because when the
weather is very hot and bright the ozone
levels go up and this contributes to
deaths particularly during heat waves